a blast furnace in lulia northern sweden
melting iron ore for steel at
temperatures of nearly 1
500 degrees celsius
it's part of a massive plant run by
swedish steel company ssab
steel is super critical for a modern
society you see it everywhere if you
start to look around you have it in
bridges you have it in cars you have it
in airplanes i myself would be able to
see a modern society without steel
actually
at the moment that's bad news for the
climate
this is a traditional way of making
steel it involves using a blast furnace
burning coal and emitting a lot of
carbon dioxide in the process and it's
why global steel manufacturing accounts
for eight percent of carbon emissions
but that is on the cusp of changing
less than a mile away a modern
alternative is taking shape
a group of companies have worked out how
to swap coal for hydrogen gas
eliminating the dirtiest bit of the
steel making process we started this in
2016. it was
in some cases perceived like a kind of a
crazy idea but
i mean now six years later we we come
tremendously far i mean it actually
works
nearby a reinforced cave stores the
project's reserves of hydrogen gas all
made using clean electricity
for sweden's energy minister innovation
and energy independence is about more
than climate change it's about being
accepted into the nato security alliance
and being protected from russian
aggression our current electricity
production is basically completely
fossil free it gives us energy security
but it also honestly helps us save the
planet so it can be habitable for
humankind in the future and i think that
in itself is a very good selling point
for for sweden's application in nato as
well
what happens with nato isn't the only
uncertainty for sweden here
decarbonizing is expensive and all the
investment in progress has yet to fully
pay off when green steel becomes
commercially available in a few years
time it will cost more and so one of the
big questions here is whether industry
and ultimately consumers are going to be
willing to pay that green premium
especially if the cost of living is
still high
at volvo the answer is resoundingly yes
they've already started planning for it
maybe it is a bit more expensive but at
the same time we do see that co2 has a
cost as well i'm so sure that our
customers in the long run will really
demand
fossil free products even though it
might be a bit more expensive in the
beginning in the long run we are sure
that this is the right batch
not everyone will be so enthusiastic
but huge leaps forward are often a
gamble and this one sweden has decided
is worth it
hannah thomas peter sky news in lulia
sweden